hi
in this session we'll talk about data q
a
a new google cloud service that viola
is using to democratize access to
bigquery
i'm abhishek kashyap product manager for
data q a
and bigquery ml at google cloud
hello i'm fabrice nicole thanks a lot to
girl for the invitation
i've been working at violia for nine
years i'm part of the iit department
and in charge of all subjects related to
daily
robotics subject for the group function
support and my main customer
finance procurement hr legal departments
thank you febreze for joining us today
in terms of the agenda
we'll start by introducing data q a
which as the name suggests
is a natural language based question
answer service
for getting insights on your bigquery
data
by just typing a question wherever you
are
we will follow it up with a discussion
on violia
which will be led by febreze
let us start with data q a
as i mentioned i am a product manager
for bigquery ml
which is another product at google cloud
to do machine learning
we have a product dashboard for various
metrics that i need to track to do my
day-to-day job
but i do have a lot of ad hoc questions
every now and then because a dashboard
board cannot
contain all the charts that i might need
in the future
as i show in this example when i want to
know how many on-demand customers
use bigquery ml last week i have to go
file a ticket and the developer has to
add a new chart to the dashboard
that takes hours two days which delays
me
in doing my work but more than that it
is a distraction
for the developer as they have to stop
doing their day job
and take care of this simple chart
with data q a now i'm just able to go
and ask that question using text and get
the answer right away
and i do not have to bother the
developer whenever i have
a question like this so what we are
doing here
is democratizing access to insights
by enabling users to ask questions in
natural language
on bigquery data
we say democratization let us see what
it entails
in this case i could ask a question in
freeform text
i did not have to know the underlying
data at all
i could just talk in what we call
business speak
rather than data speak which is what you
need for a broad set of users to use
this
there is information provided which in
this case is an interpretation of the
question
that i read and that formed
trust for me in knowing that it is
answering what i asked for
and the answer is correct fourth
i can go access it in an interface i
work in
in this case this was google sheets i
as a business user i'm working in
spreadsheets a lot
so i did not have to go open a sql
editor
and type it in there to get the answer i
need it
and finally the big query governance and
access policies that have been defined
are all taken care of automatically
there is no chance that somebody without
access to this confidential customer
information
would be able to go and get access to
this data
from this new natural language interface
the vision for data q a is for any
business user
to go to their interface of choice which
could be a chatbot a spreadsheet
or a bi platform ask a question through
natural language
and get an answer back data q a
passes the question that is asked
identifies the intent and the entities
matches those to the underlying data
generates a sequel and returns an answer
to the end user
and from this we see three key benefits
one any business user
with the appropriate access can go ask a
question and get insights when they need
it
without having to wait for somebody else
to add a chart to the dashboard
second the bi team which usually
responds
to these ad hoc requests can be freed up
and they can focus on more critical
tasks
and finally we
enable access through multiple
interfaces
so it is available wherever users work
during the alpha
this is natively available through
google sheets
and bigquery web ui we also have apis
which would allow you to embed data q a
into a chat bot or your own custom ui
so you can make it available in whatever
tool your business users work
now let us see data q a in action
we have some open source data from
instacart
that contains transaction information
along with information on the items
the location and the member
loyalty we set up data q a once
and we will show you how you can ask
questions and get insights
on three different interfaces a google
chat
chatbot google sheets
or the bigquery web ui
the experience on sheets is similar
sheets has a feature called connected
sheets that
allows you to connect to a bigquery
table and
analyze that table through the
spreadsheet itself
with data q a you can start asking
questions on that data as well
in this case the ui is richer and we are
able to even auto suggest
entities that help users get a better
experience
and make less errors in writing these
questions
to illustrate some of the more advanced
capabilities
an example question here is to compare
the average price
between two products which are values
in one of the columns in the underlying
data
and as you can see we do return the sql
as well
for a more advanced user to validate
and there is a feedback button
using which a user can signal whether
the answer was correct or not
and all of this information is passed in
to the person who set up data q a who
can view this feedback and improve the
service
for the end user
the third demo is on the bigquery ui
now we have sql analysts who are
proficient in sql
who usually come use the bigquery ui
however as you can see from one of these
example queries
some of the queries can take time to
write so we have added data q a
as a productivity function to the
bigquery ui
so you can just type a question it would
generate a query for you
that you can populate into the sql
editor
and continue to edit it earth run it as
is to summarize the features
that we just showed with data q a
you can ask a question in free form text
without having to know the underlying
data but you can
use business terminology using google
knowledge graph
we understand common synonyms we auto
suggest column names and data values
uh these are available through the api
we do accept typos so if a user makes an
error
we do not fail we come back with the
right value
and if we do not understand the question
fully
we return a clarification we are
optimized for precision
versus coverage so if we are not sure
we'll just ask
did you mean x or did you mean y
we have a setup that enables answering
incomplete questions
as an example if i just said top
products
and did not mention i wanted my revenue
revenue could have been set up as a
default metric
and we will return an answer just by
saying top products
if your tables are date partitioned we
do query the right partition to optimize
the costs
and for all bigquery governance and cost
controls that you have set up
we will work with those out of the box
i mentioned setup the reason we have a
setup component is twofold
one not all data is clean so
we have many customers who have created
views for powering end user dashboards
which have their clean data that is
trusted by the organization
data q a can be enabled on all of those
views
and provide the right answer to the end
users
second we do
want you to add business domain specific
synonyms
to the individual columns in your data
so the business users
do not have to ask questions using
column names
which as we know could be anything but
they can use the business
terminology they use day in and day out
finally we show reports of all
questions being asked and the results as
well as the status whether it was
successful if
it failed in a dashboard to the person
who sets up these tables or views
for data q a so you can continuously
monitor these
and improve the service if something is
not being answered
or if some answer does not look correct
with that i will hand it over to febreze
to talk about violia
hi fabri speaking thanks a lot tabi for
your introduction
i'm here today to tell you a story about
how we support our businesses
with innovative and digital solutions
more precisely how we reach these
targets with google support
and little bit of imagination the touch
of imagination
is called isa but we will see this idea
later
for those who don't know the audio yet
we
will provide services around three main
businesses
around the world water waste
and energy are the health of our
activities
operated by 178
000 employees through five continents
the earlier mission is to wrestle the
world we contribute
to developing access to resources
preserving
and replacing them an example is
98 million people supplied with
safe drinking water 42 million people
provided with collection services
again 41 million megawatt error
produced per year
the earlier strategic program called
impact 2023
has the objective to make violia the
benchmark company
for ecological transformation to support
this program
the vario iit department has started
since over the past year
multiple digital transformation programs
in example in 2013 with
gmail adoption from the ontario group
or in 2017 with digital workplace
setting up and public cloud adoption
and finally in 2019 with
breaking data value to our businesses
strong i.t foundation built so far by
i.t departments
support objectives of impact 2023
strategic program
to be concrete and give you an example
of difficulty we've got
within violia and i think concerned a
lot of companies around the world
i would like to tell you a story about
how we can democratize
the information access in my previous
life
when i was a consultant to find a
valuable
information was like to be a hunter in
the jungle
if you don't have the right networking
it's really an impossible mission
and finally if you catch it this one
will be out of date
or only readable by an expert
offering right affirmation to the right
population
at the right moment it's really a
challenge
who has never been upset in meeting not
to get
access directly and quickly to your own
information to the crucial data
essential to the decision making
i think about cfo who wants on-demand
and immediately act to access to revenue
or lbda figures for a specific
organization
or service manager who wants to find
quickly his remaining budget
anywhere anytime and from any devices
our dream is to democratize access to
information
and net businesses the owner on their
own information information should be
available instantly and on demand
in a simple way and business must be
confident with it
how we succeed to fulfill this business
requirement
firstly thanks to the various strategy
and transformation atmosphere
management supported us and pushed us to
be disruptive
and above all gave us the means and the
tools to meet the challenges
quality to her to formation secondly
thanks to the training program and uit
skills
digital communities have been engaged by
i.t department
to facilitate our transformation and
third
thanks to the technical tools and
partnership with google
platform as a service and google advices
speed up the availability of our
solution
for instance origin of our solution
come from exchanges with google and from
analyzer document dedicated to exploring
data with conversation this context
allowed us in four months to offer a new
digital solution
based on data lake concept and chatbot
to our businesses
our solution is called iso and
democratize
and streamline the access to the
information in order to optimize the
decision process making
our concept is based on three pillars
information self-services and access
either information because data is gold
and is essential to the decision-making
self-service to let business become
become self-sufficient
about data management and access to the
information
need to be implicitly simple and quick
our isa solution was put in life few
months ago
and helped our business to adopt the
digital transformation
a quick demo showing how iza works today
user ask question
in angular chat to either answer
is display in a small card with a web
link and when you click on that
information is published in a data
studio
pre-filtered showing the this
information
it's really an accelerator to consume
information
in a simple way
and after either what's next we never
stopped
our collaboration with with google team
a new solution
as q a looks like a good way to upgrade
our isa solution
this news and innovative functionalities
will open up a data assets view to
360 degree to our business
what are the main functionalities we
tested and we found
interested to be integrity to either
the first is there is the capabilities
of q a
to offer in real time multiple
comparison analysis
based on data available from the data
environment
second one is to produce in the tool
multiple charts based on previous
analysis related to equation
benefit for us is the
acceleration of the proposal of several
answers without configuration
by the development team
over great features based on the
multiple suggestion
offered by q a appear as an accelerator
to
the adoption of the solution
and last one but not lists q a offers
a configuration console to enrich easily
and quickly the user experience and
again
this feature optimize the time to
configure new answers
in conclusion integration of q a into
either solution
it is ugly awaited in order to offer our
businesses
and new user experiences thanks abi for
this time
and i'll let you carry on this
presentation thank you febreze for
providing us with insights
on how you are planning to use data q a
to extend your iso solution
i'll wrap up by talking about the
pricing
and pointing to some resources to get
you started
in terms of pricing data q a
is not going to have any additional
charge
you can use data q a and ask questions
in natural language
just like you could write a sql query
and get an
answer the only charge is going to be
for the underlying big query queries
that get executed and you pay for them
if you use on-demand pricing model if
you use bigquery reservations
you can use your slots as is
where you when we set up we do
index the data values in the table to
provide capabilities like autosuggest
that does carry a charge within bigquery
or use your slots
and
finally data q a
could require integration with
a chatbot or custom ui
and you may also need some help
with the setup and management on
individual data sets that you want to
enable data q a on
we have partnered with some key google
cloud
partners to help you get started
please do reach out to them if you are
working with these
to get started with data q a
as a next step if you are interested in
participating in the alpha
please reach out to your google point of
contact
or just fill the form
at the link below and we will get back
to you
thank you for your time and have a great
day
thank you
you